في الشوط الاخير صهيب من هذه الانتخابات
حاميه الوطيس في ايامها الاخيره في
حملاتها الانتخابيه التركيز يبدو انه اخذ
مسارا اخر غير كل ما كنا نسمع عنه في
الفتره الماضيه وسنعدده لاحقا اليوم وصل
الامر الى تسريب صور تعتبر بمثابه فضيحه
جنسيه لمحرم انجي احد المرشحين لسباق
الرئاسه وهو مرشح حزب البلد وقد غرد قبل
قليل قائلا انها هذه صور مفبركه وما هي
الا محاوله يائسه من جماعه فتح الله جولان
لمحاوله احباطه وثنيه عن الترشح للرئاسه
لماذا لانه هو متهم بانه سيشتت اصوات
المعارضه هو منشق عن حزب الشعب الجمهوري
هو وايضا ينطبق الامر على تشتيت الاصوات
على المرشح الرابع سنان اوغان مرشح تحالف
الاجداد او تحالف الذي يعني من اهم احزاب
وحزب الظفر فبالتالي هناك فرقاء تشتغل
فعلا من اجل ثاني هؤلاء عن الترشح لانه
سيشتت الاصوات اذا هذا بالنسبه الى تسريب
هذا الموضوع اما في الشق الاخر فهناك من
لم يسرب حتى الان ولكن تحدث عنه اردوغان
شخصيا عندما تهدد
بتسجيل او بتسريب بعض التسجيلات للقاءات
كمال كليتش دار اوغلو مرشح تحالف المعارضه
تحالف الامه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قال له بمن التقيت اين اختفيت
لمده ساعات في محطات الوقود وفي بعض
المطاعم في الولايات المتحده في اشاره الى
انه التقى بجماعه فتح الله جولن الخصم
اللدود
لاردوغان وجماعته وحليفه
السيدات اذا طاهر طيب اجريت اليوم هذه
المقابله مع رئيس حزب العداله والتنميه
الحزب الحاكم في اسطنبول ظاهر ما الذي
لمسته من حديثك الى هذا المسؤول هل حزب
اردوغان لديه ثقه كبيره دعنا نقول بان
اردوغان سيربح ولايه رئاسيه جديده في هذه
الانتخابات
واثقون جدا يعني استطيع ان اقول ذلك
بصراحه ويبدو ان الامر يتعدى الدعايه
الانتخابيه التي يروجون لها ودعني اقول
لانه يعني وعدنا المشاهدين بانه نعود الى
البرامج الانتخابيه التي كان يتم التركيز
عليها عندما سالتني في السؤال الاول بانه
هم فعلا كانوا يركزون على الحفاظ على
القيم المجتمعيه المحافظه وهذا هو صلب
حمله اردوغان الانتخابيه اضافه الى
الابقاء على اللاجئين اضافه الى الاستمرار
بموضوع سياسه الفائده اضافه الى الاستثمار
بالجنسيه وعدد من القضايا التي ذهب تحالف
الامه الى النقيض تماما فيها وفي حملاته
الانتخابيه ويدعو الى نشر الافكار
المتحرره الى موضوع الى تغيير موضوع
الفائده وبالتالي الاستقلاليه القرار قرار
البنك المركزي الى اعاده اللاجئين الى
ديارهم والى اعاده العلاقه مع الغرب كما
كانت ليس كما فعل اردوغان بالاتجاه الى رو
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات